so is Wall Street pricing in no
increases or is it pricing in uh the
interest rate actually getting cut so
their pricing in
or the FED starts cutting toward the end
of the year and that like reflects some
of those recession fears that we were
talking about because why would the FED
cut rates they would cut rates because
their policies are Rippling through the
market right people are are unable to
afford maybe homes or they pull back on
spending because things get things get
so expensive and maybe that pushes us
into a downturn and then they would have
to cut rates so it's a very nuanced
perspective but that is indeed what the
street is pricing in right now